well,
I'm going to tell you what I'm doing here in Strasbourg.
see me
I am doing right now
volunteering within the European Solidarity Body
and here I am as if I were an intern
I am a burst
yes,
I am in practice
of the university or higher grade
and I am working
for the office of international relations
of the city of Strasbourg
i.e.
the city council
they are in charge of carrying the transportation
of the European Council
and also of the European Parliament
for MEPs
and are also in charge of performing the events
that are organized within
of the board
of the parliament or also of the city council
and I am in charge of helping them as much as I can.
the truth ha ha
so nothing as usual
I mean eh a super cool experience
I highly recommend it because you learn a lot.
you don't just learn to
how they work in a country other than yours
but you are also learning a new language
and on top of that you are reinforcing another language,
English.
because in the end we communicate in English
so don't think about it ha ha